you have been very honest
about your
inability
to uh to facially identify celebrities
you
did a show about it it's such a funny
idea you don't know when you when you
see celebrities often you don't know who
they are is that true that is very true
it's not because i have facial
recognition issues
um it's because i just i don't follow
pop culture right and so um
there's a lot of i mean the show is
called under a rock if you want to look
it up but um it's uh
it's so fun and uh we only did a couple
of seasons who's one of the biggest
celebrities that you failed to identify
like someone who came up haley cuoco
wait oh you mean i thought you meant on
the show no just in general okay
whatever whatever lady gaga's assistant
was on and uh no
um
out in just my regular life i had left
the star trek
um
wrap party
and was talking to the executive
producer and this woman came around the
corner and she said
oh tig hi
and i looked at her
and i said
hey
i said wait were you just at the star
trek wrap party
and i was in toronto i just assumed
that's how she knew him yeah and she
said no it's me anne hathaway
and uh wow that's a that's a big star
and i i immediately was just like oh my
god just i just want to go home you know
and i said she said um
uh i'm and she said no amanda hathaway
um i met you backstage at the beck
concert
and i was like right hi
and um
and i remember i called stephanie after
i got up to my room
and just
said i
told her what had happened and she said
i love that anne hathaway
just explained who she was by saying
it's me ann hathaway from
back backstage at beck's concert
and she's and stephanie said and by the
way i remember
when ann introduced herself to you
backstage at beck's concert
um she said but what she should have
said to you is it's me and hathaway from
anne hathaway
[Laughter]
no it is insane to say
hi i'm i'm tom cruise from the 7-eleven
on pico totally remember we were we were
both in line and we both wanted the same
barbecue
slim jims and you were you got it before
i got it before i did but you were nice
enough to break it in half i remember
that i'm so well aware of anne hathaway
now because i was mortified uh and i
thought back that i did this show
that anne was in
beck was in bec put on at the disney
amphitheater amphitheater in downtown
los angeles but i just i just don't
follow
pop culture i but i follow other things
and that is
what
i always try to explain to people who
say there's how do you not know who anne
hathaway is or how do you not know who
oh you've never seen whatever show
what about the commercial for the show
right and i'm like well if i'm not
watching tv then i'm not seeing the
commercial right you know
but i follow music
and i follow documentaries
um
and i even follow
i love country music i love all types of
music and i don't just like
classic cool country you know right i am
familiar also with the newer country and
and so i always try and use that example
with people of
if i were to
um
introduce even though brad paisley
there's newer country than brad paisley
sure um
i remember i was at the paul simon
tribute recently and um all these
different country music and even though
you were there you didn't know who paul
simon was i'm very aware of paul simon
but there's a little guy up there what's
happening
the whole night i'm like i'm aware of
who everyone is even down to the country
singer eric church and my friend who's
sitting with me i'm like oh my god i
said oh my god i love eric church and
he's like oh i don't even know who this
guy is but that's a moment where i could
turn and be like how do you not know who
eric church is sure because it's stuff i
follow so i would be projecting on to my
friend
why don't you know who brad paisley or
eric church is
my example is in the 1940s and 50s
there were about 25 celebrities and
that's all there were yeah and everybody
knew who everybody was yeah and so
there's jerry lewis oh my god
you know there's jack benny here comes
doris day later
but now
uh and i do believe it's been i think
it's been
proven uh people that study the human
brain say that because
the world has changed much more quickly
than we could ever you know than our
brains could ever adapt to so we have
these brains that are meant to know
about 45 people in a village
that's kind of what we're supposed to
know and yet we are being asked to know
what are you talking about it's the
biggest loser yeah don't you know
you know jerry the biggest loser who
lost 25 pounds in a week that's jerry
halligan who lost 25 pounds and then he
cried when he accidentally broke down
and ate all that custard out of a out of
a out of a milk pail you know and and so
but i know who eric church is i know but
i i'm constantly when i
when i go into um you know the
supermarket and i'm going through the
checkout thing i'll see a magazine and i
won't know who anybody is on the cover
because it will say things like
you know sheila
tells
brooke benson you've got one last chance
buddy boy
and i don't know who any of them are and
then i always look up at it says sheila
from you've got an onion that's my hat
uh and brooke benson from you know
got a dollar got a dollar i'll give you
a peso you know reality shows
this is all real no there's a guy named
aunt anstead yeah i don't know i don't
know who that is i know who he is okay
i ask my listeners and we have a lot of
listeners we're this isn't you know
we're this isn't some uh punk ass
operation we've got a lot of listeners
out there who the [ __ ] is aunt antstad
because i'll just see things that are
like aunt dance ted said i don't know
that since the breakup i'm still pretty
sad yeah issues
yeah well no we can't find him we've
been looking he doesn't exist yeah i've
never even heard the name who is he he
he he used to date the woman who was on
i think it was flipper flop
and then
they got married then they broke up and
now he's dating renee zellweger so okay
but what you did is it took you seven
moves yeah he was on flip flap and fly
yeah and he was with janine and then she
got the onion right then she got the
onion and he went over it too so yeah
and then renee yeah
yeah and then they went over to the show
who wants to buy a mule and then um
and then they split up and then they
went with you know and what happens is
it's this system that
and i honestly uh
it's no skin off my back i just don't
know who these people are and i don't
have enough time in life to figure it
out you know it's funny because
uh
there is also
we ha i only did two seasons we lost our
sponsor for um
under a rock it was it was i think you
just i think you just met your sponsor
and didn't know who it was and that's
how you like it
who the [ __ ] are you
i'm the guy
i can't believe you don't know who i am
i'm the sponsor um i'm cancelling this
show that's what we could get maybe we
can get hop to sponsor the next season
of under a rock yeah but we um
what was the uh oh stephanie asked me
recently if i knew who this woman was um
gosh i don't i don't know her name but
she's
this is going nowhere but stephanie
always has those moments of like oh my
god that would be the perfect person for
under a rock she's so she's on that hbo
show
um that's like really popular euphoria
yes oh
zendaya oh i had never heard of it yeah
and here's the thing what happens is
that you have kids and i know all this
stuff through my kids
your kids are too young so they know
like who the wiggles are right but
they're not gonna say oh my god zendaya
um
my kids inform me this is where i get
all my information now now occasionally
i try and give them information right
you know there was a civil war in
america yeah
1961-1865 i get shut down could be
another any day now i get shut down fast
but uh
but damn it i know who zendaya is my
wife thought mick jagger's last name was
irish like mick jagger
well that's i mean that's horrifying i
shouldn't out her like that but
mick jagger like like she didn't know
his name was mick like
jagger she thought she didn't know his
first name and thought his last name was
man she thought john and paul was john
and paul one person she thought there
were three people in the beatles there's
john and paul and then there's ringo and
george
yeah that's um that's a little scary she
doesn't know who mick jagger you guys
remember like the third lead from a show
in the 70s that was on for one season
that's important but that's important oh
that's what's more important than like
zendaya or
you know what i do i have i do know
minor character actors
there was a guy who always played the
old man in tv shows in the 70s and his
name was bert mustin and and as a kid
he would show up on like archie bunker
saying well i i lost my penny and you
know what i mean can you help me our
chief bunker and i go like hey it's bert
mustin on the latest episode that just
came out you referenced tova borgnine's
lawyer ernest borgnine's wife's yeah of
course i always knew stuff like that i'm
just saying that
um
my mind is filled now and i know lots of
arcane stuff about history and i know
lots of minor characters in history so
what happens is your brain gets filled
and now the doorbell rings and it's aunt
anstead and he's saying can i have a
brain cell my i borrow one and i'm like
no no because you don't want to give up
burt musk i was gonna can he get can he
take tova
organizing no no no i'm with you ernest
bortner was was was the [ __ ] and yeah
and tova borgnine really got him through
a lot she was a rock
but your entire career was about like
pop culture and like promoting things
like how do you not know this
stuff i'll often say oh that person
seems really great i wish i knew more
about them and people will say they were
on your show seven times
from 1993 to
you know 20
22. i'm not purposefully avoiding stuff
it's just it's not i'm not there's
certain things i'm just not it's not
it's just not on my radar it's so crazy
now because there are some people who
start out on the fringe
and then they become so big
just through this
process that's mysterious to all of us
that everyone has to reckon with them it
just occurred to me that vladimir putin
knows who pete davidson is
like you you know that vladimir putin
has been like
have you seen
he was not he has not been on snl for
several weeks you know
and it was pete davidson and they're
like you got to really focus on the war
we're in right now okay but he's
troubling i don't know is he's going to
leave is he with the jenners now how
does it work
does he go with the kardashians you know
like you know that that's how big pete
davidson is now and god bless him but
he's that that huge figures that are
affect the future of the world yeah he's
taking up one or two brain cells in
there
absolutely and um you know aunt anstead
hasn't quite achieved that yet but he's
getting there because he's in my head
now i mentioned talking about him sorry
yeah on this huge podcast well of course
because he was on flop flipped and flune
you know flip flop what no
was it we'll fix your flu it was a show
about chimneys so it's just a show about
beach sandals you guys don't you guys
don't watch hgtv at all only when i'm in
a hotel oh it's the best